I want to repeat the quote that you just
said with conviction at that upfront you
said Latinos are a force in this country
and it's time for TV to reflect who the
moderate Latino actually is not who we
are believed to be can you expand on
that how his TV fallen short for me it's
always been about a lot of stereotypes
and even though I think things have
changed you see more Latinos on TV it's
not really a reflection of who the
modern Latino is this is an
english-speaking network there's a lot
of Spanish Network that for us yeah but
this is an english-speaking that for the
modern Latino it's it's a different
thing and it and it requires different
programming it requires a very targeted
agenda why why this why now I mean you
clearly have got so much else going on
yes
but I think when Nouveau first came to
me they came to me maybe just for me to
be the face of the network and when they
sat down and when I sat down with
Michael Schwimmer and we really started
talking I think he realized I had a lot
of ideas about the network and what it
should be and and programming for
Latinos
so my point of view came from my
upbringing you know I grew up watching
Marcia Brady or Rudy Huxtable but I
didn't really see myself and when I
think about growing up in the Bronx and
and watching TV I think about like once
a year West Side Story would come on and
this this movie inspired me so much you
know to do everything that I've done and
I just when I thought about Nouveau in
the network I thought this is a great
way to empower and uplift the community
because if I could be inspired by just
one movie once a year that my mom had to
make sure that we watched at
Thanksgiving you came on O then if you
had a cable network that was 24 hours a
day with programming that was relatable
where I saw myself work imagine how many
people could be inspired and imagine how
many things could be done I just I saw
it as a real opportunity to to empower
Anna
so how was your role gonna work are you
gonna be there day and day out well
everybody knows I can't be there day in
and day out but I'm the chief creative
officer so I the whole look and feel of
a network I'm involved in and involved
in creatively so you know marketing and
how the marketing looks how the network
looks itself the programming the
development of the programming being in
distribution meetings and all that kind
of stuff you know it's it's a big job
but for me it's really important because
for me like I said it represents
something bigger than just television
you know it represents doing something
for this community that has been so
underserved for so long talk about those
distribution meetings what were they
there's a little weird no and they
actually were great they were very
educational for me you know I am such a
creative person I come from such a
creative slant all the time I'm always
thinking about stories and all that and
the distribution was a totally different
thing but I think what I learned from
them was really that everybody's trying
to target this community everybody's
trying to figure it out and crack crack
that nut and it's it's it's it's not an
easy thing you know how did your
celebrity help in those meetings and how
do you think it'll help help launch this
network I think being a celebrity
everybody thinks okay bring awareness
which is an obvious thing and that's
true but I also you know I've had 20
years in front of and behind the camera
so one thing that I do bring is
relationships you know just with our
partnership and association we've
already attracted different talent
different you know the agencies are
willing to work with us in a different
way just everybody just directors and
writers and all that kind of stuff it's
just it makes a huge difference so we're
able to kind of be able to boost the
programming and boost the quality of the
programming in a way that hasn't been
done before for this community when
you're in those distribution meetings so
they was their idea or some people's
idea of what works for the tea no
television is you know a lineup of
telenovelas I mean that's what has to be
so I don't think you know everybody here
you're dealing with a bunch of smart
people I just don't think they
understand it you know when you grow up
as a mother I am a modern Latino so I
understand it I know what I saw and what
I didn't see I know how it affected me
and how it didn't affect me so I'm able
to bring that knowledge and of course my
whole family and all of my friends I'm
able to bring that knowledge to it say I
want to see this I don't want to see
that you know and at the end of the day
art great art great television which you
have to have great television these days
because television is so cutting edge is
it's just about making quality doing
quality stories and really making great
television you know and so that's what I
feel we have to concentrate on this
should be a network not only that draws
in all the Latinos but also anybody you
know I often think of this movie The Joy
Luck Club because I remember watching it
when I was young and knowing never
having been to the to the Far East and
knowing nothing about the Asian culture
in any way shape or form but this movie
touched me so much and I was I was young
at the time I don't know if you guys
remember that movie but it was by Wayne
Wayne who I worked with and made of
Manhattan and so I knew the movie very
well and it just it was a great story
you know it didn't matter that it was
about Asians it didn't matter that it
was about that culture you saw yourself
in it every street it's some story in
that movie touched every single person
and and that's what I feel great art
does and I think with the nouveau
Network that's what we want to
accomplish we want to accomplish just
great art great programming that of
course is targeted toward the modern
Latino but at the end of the day you
know you will tune in to BT so well I
you will tune in to MTV even though it's
for a younger number episode you know
it's it's that for me that's the goal do
you know yet what the perfect nouveau TV
show is can you define it right now the
perfect TV yes it's a lot of different
things I think honestly there's gonna be
so many facets to us because that's
really trying to put us in a box again
and I think that you can I think that
we're very diverse and I think there's a
lot of different things that interest us
one of my wish list for the cover for
the thing is is to to infuse more music
I feel like when you
think about networks that were launched
and were targeted toward a specific
demographic like a B et or an MTV like I
said for the younger generation there
was a they drew them in with music first
and then the network grew from there and
I think that we can do that with nouveau
TV so that's one of my one of my things
that I'm always kind of music so that
makes a question when will we see you
well for the launch there are so there
are some programs that I'm involved with
so you're gonna see me on probably
sooner rather than later again we're
just infusing the network right now with
energy this is a long term project and
goal like any network
Bravo Network any of these networks it
takes years and years to get it right
but I feel like we're on such a fast
track and we're on such a good with with
Bill Hillary now coming on as a head of
programming who worked at Comedy Central
and who worked at the BBC with our new
marketing off a head of marketing Jennie
we just were on the right track already
and this new energy that we infuse for
the launch in July it's just a taste of
where we're going you'll get the new
look you'll get the new feel but you
know we want to go into scripted you
know that's that's a big thing for me
that I push for two because I feel like
one show can launch a network one
amazing show and we're constantly on the
lookout for that now your production
company will sell to Nuvo TV are you
absolutely are you dead everybody okay
so you're not exclusive okay now you
also there's some things were announced
at the upfront yesterday I mean last
month was a special involving you as one
of them correct yes yes yes what is what
will it be well we're doing this one of
the things that was important to me too
with this network was to have some
education let's say not hit you over the
head education but education in an
interesting way I don't feel like you
can go anywhere on CB and get any of our
Latino important figures or their
history you know whether it's politics
or comedians or actors or writers or
directors or you know like I said
political figures you just you know
historical figures who people who change
things who had different turning points
in their life that led them to a path
that was that that well
being very inspiring or aspirational and
so one of the the the shows that we're
doing is is is aimed at that and I'll be
the first episode because I was
available now is there a chance that
maybe you'll train on some relationships
and try to win some producers to do
shows for Lou absolutely I mean we're
going to everybody you know I work with
CAA and I work with a lot of great which
is a great agency and has a wealth of
writers and directors and and and
obviously actors but all of our all of
my relationships I'm calling on for this
because I really do feel like it's an
important it's an important initiative I
don't wanna say initiative but it's an
important I don't know what the word is
it's just bigger it's bigger than than
just a channel of all your
accomplishments where does this rank or
where will this rank especially in terms
of your legacy
oh my legacy you talk about your legacy
already already I don't want to you know
have fun creating the shows I don't know
I just I wanna I think of what I want is
for it to be remembered as a place where
we gave a home to artists that didn't
have a home before a real place to go
and where Latino artists in front of and
behind the camera had a place to tell
their stories to tell our stories and
that at the end of the day that we've
changed literally change the face of
television hmm I gotta ask you I'm not
sure if you have time to watch
television are there any shows on TV now
that you feel like speak to you speak to
a modernity no hmm gonna have to get
back to you on that the Fosters that's
the most important question I don't
understand how are you gonna balance
this with going back to American Idol
and saving it what yeah that's just a
rumor I'm aiming to be had no I'm not
now I don't have any announcement to
make on that front right now I'm
concentrating on the unbuilding this
network and a couple other businesses I
have and also just working on my on my
10th album so tenth album yeah Wow
ladies and gentlemen Jennifer Lopez
thank you